what's up everybody welcome to another
league of legends business QA let me
just go to twitch and say what's up guys
super excited to be back it's been it's
been a while I feel like it's been
forever but I guess it's only since it's
been since Friday a lot has happened in
in my life since then so it feels like
it's been a while I'm excited to be back
though and i had my usual co-host three
she kept TV rishi welcome back Thank You
Evan so happy to be here comfortable of
everyone top of love Jay rises in game
with me he wants to do an experiment
when we go bot Lane so I'm gonna go lot
first and jungle second and wait wait
hold on did he say that he wants to be
heimer as support all I know is he's
saying my mood exited host mode I
thought I feel my end today's experiment
I want to go back to heimer you go team
oh but we go to the bottling so he wants
to play heimer support I think okay well
we're gonna do yes he said yes okay
experiments heimer support it is I our
support okay uh what's a couple love
what else what's what's the coffee of
the day is well I needed my coffee today
if it's that gothic on that [ __ ] but I
was you know we didn't stream yesterday
because you were recording your audio
book which was super exciting I don't
know if you want to go into that a
little bit again today for this audience
but yeah I got to catch up on some much
needed sleep yesterday morning so as
much as I I missed everybody I'm happy
that I am waking up this morning with
more caffeine and awakeness I love it I
love it I'm just trying to clarify with
JR eyes that we're doing heimer support
because this is a definitely
non-traditional bot Lane that we're
trying
do so should be exciting um yeah
yesterday was booked audio day I spent
the morning from not the morning the
whole day from ten ten to five recording
the audio book which was super exciting
I missed I missed you guys I miss doing
this but but it was fun oh we didn't get
our our lane so I'm I'm jungle okay well
jungle it is while we sort this out
though why don't we get to our first
question what do we got give a shout-out
dear young let's shut up let's see I'm
off my game here I'm not used to this
now shout out to solar solar gag 2453
what's up welcome welcome who else we
have rise online where she kept see row
third la de the initial plan was to do
Teemo a DC but it we didn't get lined up
like that so I'm doing Teemo jungle and
we don't play rent not on these
experiments alright welcome everybody on
twitch and live let's go let's get this
a question okay first questions coming
from to Farah to Farah is saying my
question is what advice would you give
entrepreneurs in Africa and other
developing nation unfortunately i can't
i can't attend the session today oh i
think this was in response to one of
your live stream because of my poor
network connection but he signs off
believing in zimbabwe so uh too far as
thanks for the question the first thing
that came to mind or you know kind of
general advice for anyone who's in
africa or developing nation oh oh I just
got so badly oh no I wasn't paying
attention
listen to you and then I made a huge
mistake oh no what happened i ban teemo
advanta moans I thought were I thought
we were I thought I was picking tiro and
it was my turn to ban and I banged my
own champion oh okay well yeah we live
and learn I'm gonna go Eve then very sad
okay ah you've had good time to be
though but I know that's that yeah yeah
it's all good Jay Wright says should we
jawed it's all good okay oh I'll give
you more time but you need to get in the
game no no no I just this is what
happened see you lose you lose this you
lose the skills when you take too long
up no it's all good it's all good okay
so yes Africa entrepreneurs in Africa
Africa yeah so um I guess the first
thing I would just say is that you know
whatever you're going to end up doing
because there isn't really any specific
specifics about his or her business but
i think that the greatest strength
you'll have is to differentiate your
business and really owning what makes
you different how you see the world
differently because you being from
Zimbabwe is going to give you a
perspective and then you as an
individual living in Zimbabwe you're
going to have a unique perspective and
so whatever you decide to do embrace how
you are different and embrace how you
are unique and embrace how you uniquely
see the world and really own it be
confident about it and and incorporate
that into whatever you do because I
think that is you know that's what will
set you apart I mean there's a lot of
other advice I know that we could give
you but that's kind of where I felt
there was value
can you read the question back to
specifics about why Africa I mean I'm
sorry I'm Africa but what was the dis
general advice I wanted yeah just
general advice for anyone who's an
Africa or other adult developing nation
yeah okay so the first thing I would
think about is not letting that be an
excuse or a reason for you you know a
lot of people say well because I'm gonna
develop a nation I can't have success as
an entrepreneur there's been tons of
people coming out of Africa who've had a
lot of success we've covered a ton of
the money on the channel to people who
you know I didn't know a lot about
before but but have gone on to have
massive success and in not letting that
be the reason why you don't go off and
then kill it right just because you're
in a developing country doesn't mean you
have a developing mindset or developing
business you can be just as successful
as we are here and you can apply that to
anything you know I'm too young to old
it all the education I don't want the
parents at on the background any of that
stuff so I would I would do my best to
eliminate that mindset I would surround
myself with stories resources people
that built me up you know if it's having
strive messy you are on the wall or
whoever it is that you look up to to
know that you can make it and also I'm
understanding that it's a global
marketplace to write you could sell
stuff online right I mean I'm here in
Canada and most of my audiences in the
US but then also around the world you
know the amount that i sell to canadians
is tiny compared to where i'll sell
around the world and so it's so much
easier it's so much easier to get
started now to have a huge impact oh I
have sounds on here
um that there's no excuse anymore
there's no excuse anymore and it's just
overcoming that the limiting mindset
that you have that it's a I'm Africa
from Africa where I'm from a developing
country everything it's all the same
it's all hustle it's all hard work it's
all providing value it's just going out
and doing it do the work and you'll have
you'll have the same chance of success
as the rest of us that's what I got nice
and you know Evan I I've been looking
out because I know we had a lot of
callers from or people asking questions
from Africa and and kind of in that same
place in their mindset about you know
how can maybe how can they be successful
their businesses I recently ran by a
tweet by Stephen Kelly about startups in
Africa using tech and there's a lot of
tech opportunities that he was
highlighting in this particular tweet
and things so I'm always looking out to
see kind of what's going on but I think
there's much more than people realize
and I think it might also just require a
little bit of resourcefulness in terms
of finding out what's going on for
entrepreneurs in your area because I
think there's more than then I think
people realize yeah yeah I you know oh
one hundred percent at the same time if
there's nothing go and make it
oh right or join an online group right
or come here or you know add comments to
believe nation videos you know just
because you're not in the big city
doesn't mean that you can't go out and
get the support you need for your
business cool all right got lots of
people in the chat today want to shout
out as you come in off the sourcebook
welcome back last minute Lewis hi Louie
Louie welcome argument I China the
little is Joe Lewis a buddy of mine is
an entrepreneur here in Toronto runs
last minute training oh yeah cool the
last minute Louie welcome um did I miss
anyone oh we got aunt from our gratitude
stream last minute or no breathe fitness
you know Anthony from over at our
earlier strain this morning i love it
welcome aboard guys I yeah cool the
happy guide all right next question
coming from da dee da dee says is it
necessary for collaboration in any
business it's not what type of business
needs collaboration is a necessity I
will be expecting me hear from you soon
yeah you know what came to mind actually
and I don't believe this business had
was had any partners there was this mom
preneur who was hugely successful and
she was featured on the shark tank and
anyway she made these products for
children and basically assoc was an
inventor and entrepreneur she sold
children's products on a retail website
and I think she had like two million
sales annually and I did she was
literally doing everything out of her
own house with the help of family but I
don't think there was any you know major
partners and I and she was obviously a
hugely profitable business so I think
it's definitely possible to have a
business about partnerships but but yeah
I think one of the advantages of a
partnership would be if someone has a
skilled in an area that you don't like
one thing about this mom preneur was
that she was super brilliant super on
fire and like you know may not be the
average Scylla preneur and so if you
aren't able to do everything on your own
one of the advantages of partnership is
getting someone who can kind of be
strong in areas where you're not not so
strong so I think it's a personal
decision based on your business where
you want to go you know how big you want
to get that that sort of thing okay well
I just died ah that's all good um so
much you just do I need to have a
partnership to be successful as a mum
preneur well I think it wants just
information on businesses and
collaborations like when is it necessary
when is it not yeah that's a great
question i think a lot of entrepreneurs
have to deal with it um i think it
starts with understanding what your
skill set is and how much you need to
have support for what you're doing so
are you able to do everything yourself
or are you really out of depth and one
of the things that you're trying to do
so as an example of my first business we
were selling biotech software now i am
not a programmer i can't i can't create
you know the code for for what we need
oh we're about to fight about the fight
or about the fight maybe uh oh that is
here
so I I can't do everything myself I you
know and my partner is they couldn't do
it all on their own either they needed
to have support so that worked out well
where I did a lot of the business stuff
and media stuff and partnership stuff in
and they did a lot of the coding work
and programming and all of that other
stuff to help the business go in this
business you know I could do a lot of
the stuff at least the early stage stuff
myself I could you know I don't need a
business partner to edit videos as an
example something that I wanted to
eventually build a team in higher up so
it starts with an honest self audit to
know what you're good at and where you
might be able to need some help if it's
a critical business function that you
don't know how to do then it's something
to think about having a business partner
come in and help you with it when you're
going into a business partnership I
would just make sure you understand that
it's let's make a noise I'm training I
understand that it's it's people jump
into partnerships too soon so many times
they jump into partnerships too soon
they feel like oh you're really good at
marketing I'm really get a product so
let's let's do a joint partnership where
you really need to you know date before
you get married and make sure that
that's something that you really really
really like this person and can go
through the hard times with this person
not just the good times I'm so let's
start and at the same time I'd say if
you don't have it you don't have that
partnership don't stress yet don't don't
not take action you got to keep moving
forward on your business regardless oh
we gotta kill good job team first killa
for our team yeah uh oh that is coming
yeah so those are my thoughts it may be
it may mean that you need to have
somebody or or may not just depends on
the on the what you feel is lacking in
your business mm-hmm home already um
anything you want to help but the game
right now uh we're losing we're one in
30 in one I gotta make up for that
really really death but we'll see you
it's still early we'll see how it goes
I'm filming I still believe i still
believe i still can't believe i bain't
emo though it's pretty pretty ricky
mistake there but it's all good all
right experiments the next question
comes from Maddie or muddy muddy and
maddie is 50 50 year old female from
Egypt she's trying to find a job in our
country and she sailed many many times
and she finally found a job in Saudi
Arabia but she's struggling because she
says my biggest problem internal fear is
about losing my job or will I be will I
not be successful how can I overcome
this mental block she says she also has
like back and back pain and things but
she's just feeling like nervous from
having failed a lot in trying to find a
job and now she has a job in this afraid
to lose lizet so she's afraid of losing
the job that she has right now yeah
she's afraid she won't be a success
because she's just had a lot of failure
yeah so obviously very natural fear when
you've had when you've experienced
failure in a particular area over and
over so I think it helps to first just
congratulate yourself and give yourself
props for having kept trying after a
lots of failure because usually when we
experience both the failure it just gets
harder and harder to keep trying but
clearly you're tenacious you continue to
go for it in spite of obstacles but yeah
I think how to overcome fear as a lot to
do with your mindset and I know you
recognize that because you recognize as
a mental block one of the things that I
do it when I'm dealing with fear is
either one remember the time when I was
afraid and then it turned out okay so
the first thing is to like try to think
about you know when was I afraid and
then I found out there actually wasn't a
reason to be afraid and just kind of
think and meditate on those times when
things worked out but also I think just
whether it's talking to yourself or
watching a video surround yourself with
material that counters that theater so
like I'll just speak to myself sometimes
like you know if I'm feeling afraid I
will say to myself certain things that
that I know help me in that moment to
not be overtaken by that beer what are
you better than anything it seems like
there's a lot of lot of questions all in
one so we're talking about
dealing with fear deal with failure and
what was the third part um overcoming
this mental block is that the one you
meant or because she's got the fear of
the fact that she failed she's got the
fear of not being successful at her job
kind of the same I guess and then how to
overcome that mental block good okay so
a couple things fear of failure is about
all of its normal i just died again holy
cow my team um youyou don't overcome the
fear failure at least mm at least in my
mind you just you feel the fear and you
do it anyway if you're afraid of
something you you you it's not this
correct answer isn't going in and being
unafraid you're gonna be afraid it's I
know I think a lot of people make that
mistake where they feel like oh because
I'm afraid I shouldn't do it and all
these people have had success and it
looks like they're not afraid they were
terrified when they first started you
know when I first was doing YouTube
videos I was terrified but it's feeling
that fear and just doing it anyway and
so whatever it is that you want to try
to do it's understanding that that's
totally normal and it's just something
you have to get through and the thing
that helped me at least get through it
was thinking about trying not to live
with regret in my life so if I'm ever
afraid of something even like even
during the audiobook right like I'm
afraid to go to the studio and do
something new and it's a it's a it's a
big deal and this is where Justin Bieber
records his his albums and you know this
all of this potential failure in that
maybe I won't do a good job or maybe my
throat
we saw or maybe you won't do it you know
good as I can but I still went right
like I didn't want to not show up
because even worse than the fear failure
is knowing that you didn't do your best
knowing that you shied away when you
could have done more mm-hmm and so I try
to live with that regret as much as i
can because it's so kind of haunted me
before in terms of not in terms of being
fired from a job but you wanted to keep
your job if you want to keep your job
just do a good job you know it sounds
maybe really it's not meant to offend
but you just you do a good job if you do
a good job they'll keep you on and
they'll look for other ways like out if
I was working at a company I would want
to look for ways to add so much value
that they couldn't imagine me not being
there that they would want to go out and
find other opportunities for me to to
help because i am doing such a great job
right where if they're saying there's a
new project coming up how do i become
the default person that they want to
give it to because i've done such a good
job on projects in the past for them so
it's always just looking to do more but
do your do your job and do a little bit
more than your job as well to get ahead
o team is suffering can I get anything
from this well I'm just gonna die die
man these guys are good oh oh I gotta
kill all right um I mean I've told this
story a couple times where we were and
this is also for entrepreneurs not just
not just people who are in jobs you know
you there's a fear of losing your client
right what if the client doesn't keep me
on board anymore well do an amazing job
for that client you know don't just sell
a product or service being indispensable
part
of their operations so that they would
rather you know get rid of somebody on
their team before they lost you as a
provider that's what I got love it and I
like how the value your message about
value you know trance and
entrepreneurship it's like whether you
are an employee or you're the employer
when you add value you're never going to
lose I mean I guess you still lose
sometimes but it's not because you
didn't do what you were supposed to do
you know yeah it's just it's everything
in life it's relationships you know it's
jobs its relationships it's it's it's
everything if you want to have success
you want your relationship to work out
well then you need to provide value
right good you knew a gauger your spouse
your boyfriend your girlfriend to to
feel valued because of what you're doing
for them whether it's you know listening
to them or just being a shoulder to cry
on or helping them through problems in
their life or whatever it is you know if
if you're not adding value to the person
in your life it was you're supposed to
be your significant other than you know
that relationships not gonna last very
long same thing with friendships you
know it's it's everything we're going
meta yeah no it's awesome i love it i
mean sofort 2453 says I was in a company
where I worked so hard but it was the
type of company where that doesn't work
hard to imagine so I left in the end and
went for my own company yeah and then
last minute Louis said not all employers
are smart enough to recognize the added
value yeah and I and then I say so I
think it comes down to two just really
recognizing that you're doing it for you
because you want to provide value and
you want to feel good about the work
that you're putting out there whether
it's your job whether it's your business
whether it's your relationship you're
not necessarily always yes you want to
get the results but sometimes you can't
control what the other person is going
to do but you can at least feel proud
that you gave your back yeah a neta neta
works out so you know not not every
relationship is going to be whoa I am
dying I died not every relationship is
gonna they're going to recognize like if
you're the most caring individual and
you pour everything into the
relationship not all the time they're
not always going to reciprocate and so
the answer is you have to go find
somebody else right it's not staying
this bad relationship for the rest of
your life it's not stay in a bad job or
career with bad clients for the rest of
your life let's go off and do something
else right and eventually that's going
to work out but somebody not everybody
will recognize the value great the
people don't recognize your value and
you're giving everything you have you
don't want to be around those people
anymore go find a new relationship I
same you know some some customers won't
appreciate all the value that you
provide and they just call you up and
give you headaches and yell at you and
berate you you know that's those aren't
people that you want to stick around
mm-hmm but that doesn't mean that the
answer but the answer is still the
answer is still going to provide value
right like it doesn't change the advice
it just means go off and oh oh we lost
all right I gotta kill we lost um yeah
short game didn't do so well in that
game so it's just like if you're trying
to get in you know you have this passion
for a business and it doesn't work it
doesn't mean you give up the first time
that
that it fails right and I mean I do like
your advice to we shouldn't say that the
you value the process you have to you
know you're doing it not only to get
ahead and not only to you know get that
promotion or get the bigger deal you're
doing it because you feel it's the right
thing to do you're you're you're trying
to help you're being nice you're over
delivering because it makes you feel
good as well as hopefully furthers the
you know the career or job opportunity
or you know relationship but that
outcome is not the only goal it's not
it's not the main reason you do it
because you want to do it and ideally
you you're around people who recognize
that that awesomeness and support you
and build you up so yes not everybody's
gonna not everybody is going to
recognize it but doesn't matter get rid
of those people and start focusing on
the ones who who do recognize it and do
feel appreciated and valued and give me
the good opportunities oh I thought that
was a good way to end the fish yeah so I
went 4 and 6 and our team went 7 and 21
I got over half of our kills but the
team was nice feeding hard anyway so
well that was a failed experiment but
you never know right you know what what
you know je vais suggested something new
I was pumped to try it we didn't get it
I then burned out my own champion you
know we still went for it and it might
have been the greatest thing ever you
know but this time it didn't work out
that's fine we're still gonna bring it
for the next game um cool well it's been
fun Rishi what are we going to end on
what's the Rishi wisdom of the day here
oh and you know it cup of value give
value today in every area of your life
whether it's job or your relationship
your friendship give value I love it
well thank you guys for watching have an
awesome day what else anything else you
need to talk about it's only tuesday i
feel like it's thursday and we got to do
live streams more live streams coming up
although this thursday is going nuts
it's full-on full-on no breaks it's it's
straight into live streams they move
like eight or nine live streams so go
yeah hella hello laughs laughs with you
at nine right uh last time I had calls
and live stream so it wasn't always
online but this time it's selling at all
it's all YouTube hang out so it's going
to be fun cool well thank you guys for
watching thank you for the questions
thank you for the love and the in the
chat hopefully it helped you and you got
some wisdom go off and crush today have
an awesome Antrel adventure go try
something new and add value as we she
was talking about continue to believe or
whatever your one word is and we'll see
you soon